[Musique] c'est ainsi que
Rames, je suis une poète et
écrivaine militante de
[Musique] L'
Afghanistan, puis l'Afghanistan est tombé entre les
mains des talibans, moi et ma famille avons juste
fui aux Pays-Bas et cela fait presque
deux ans que je vis  Les Pays-Bas
avec ma famille, euh mais tu sais, ça fait
toujours partie de ma vie et une partie de
ma famille est euh en
Afghanistan. L'histoire a commencé à partir
du moment où les talibans ont interdit d'
écrire de la poésie en Afghanistan, puis euh, je
publie un appel.  euh à tous les poètes
du monde entier, s'il vous plaît, écrivez des
poèmes de solidarité avec le peuple
afghan et contre la censure
et la répression en Afghanistan parce que
vous savez que l'Afghanistan est le seul pays
où toutes sortes d'art sont interdites par
[Musique]
Taliban ce livre  a un message si fort
pour tous les gens du
monde entier qu'ils ne doivent pas
se taire quand on voit beaucoup de catastrophes
qui se sont produites dans un pays comme
[Musique] l'
Afghanistan alors qu'en Afghanistan, le
15 janvier 2023, les talibans ont interdit la poésie,
euh pour les poètes  et tout aussi avant cela,
ils ont interdit toute sorte d'art
en
Afghanistan. Je pensais juste que je devrais
faire certaines choses et c'est pourquoi j'ai
publié un appel à tous les points
du monde qui ne se
taisent pas et ne font pas quelque chose pour  solidarité
avec le peuple afghan, en particulier
avec les femmes, les artistes et le PS en
Afghanistan